قال القيادي في حركه حماس اسامه حمدان ان
تداعيات جريمه الاباده الجماعيه في قطاع
غزه لها حدود غير تلك التي وضعها الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي واستنكر حمدان و باشد العبارات
بيان المفوض العام للاونروا وايضا قرار
اداره الوكاله بفصل عدد من الموظفين دون
تحقيق مهني وبناء على مزاعم الاحتلال فقط
بدعوى مشاركتهم في عمليات السابع من
اكتوبر واوضح حمدان انه بتلك الخطوه تثبت
بل تبنت اداره الوكاله الروايه الكاذبه
للاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ان الخطوه التي اقدمت عليها
اداره الاونور بفصل عدد من الموظفين بناء
على مزاع ما اوردها العدو الصهيوني بدعوى
مشاركه هؤلاء الموظفين في احداث السابع من
اكتوبر ودون تح تحقيق او حتى تحقق من هذه
الم المزاعم هي خطوه مستنكره وتفتقد
لادنى المعايير والمقومات المهنيه وتحرف
بوصله الوكاله التي اسست لمهمه اساسيه هي
حمايه اللاجئين الفلسطينيين واغاثه لا ان
تتبنى روايه الاحتلال وتبطش بالفلسطينيين
الى جانب الاحتلال